[Music]
hello everyone
something too serious today really i
would say
um privileged to be talking to
janmi park born in
1993 in north korea
author of in order to live 2015 a book
which i just finished reading today
and human rights activist and ted
speaker yonmi park grew up in a
punishing totalitarian society based on
stalinist and
maoist principles perhaps the last
stellarist-era totalitarian state on
earth and devoted
to the worship of kim jong-il and his
family
but at the age of 13 she and her family
made a daring escape to china
in search of a life free of tyranny and
indeed a life at all
in her viral talks viewed
online nearly 350 million times and in
her book
park urges audiences to recognize
think about and resist the oppression
that exists in north korea and
around the world hi there
hi dr peterson it's an honor to be on
your show
it's very nice to see you i finished
about the last third of this book
this morning and it's it makes for
harrowing reading
there's no doubt about that so
you lived through some of the harshest
times i would say you and your family
likely lived through some of the
harshest times in north korea in the 90s
after
the berlin well wall fell and and the
russian communists stopped supporting
north korea's economy
maybe we could start i think by just
allowing you to
tell your story so you can start
wherever you'd like and
thank you exactly as you mentioned in
the
after soviet union collapsed they were
stop helping north korean regime
and north korean regime is like run by
central government economy
so they decide how much how much rice
you can eat that day per person
based on their class so even though the
biggest irony of north korea is that
it was founded the idea of equality make
everybody the same
the communism and then they call it
themselves as a
socialist paradise but they made it into
north koreans into three big
categories of classes and within three
categories
they divided 50 subcategories of classes
so it became the most unequal society
that you can imagine right now in our
human history
uh i was born in the northern part of
north korea
so during this uh that great famine that
was man-made
feminine by king regime that's where
most of north koreans died in the
northern part where i was born
and the people in kenya in the capital
they were still very fed
so the modern example that i found was
actually the hunger games
there is a capital and they divide 13
different districts
they make everybody else out of the
capital on verge of surviving
so people do not think about what is the
meaning of life
what is freedom all they have to think
about is next
meal like can i find food to feed my
child
and in pyongyang they are really very
fed and they have
every intention to maintain the system
and the regime
so that's where i was born at i mean in
the 1993
of seeing the dead bodies on the streets
it was a literally everyday thing
i never knew that that was like weird
words
and that's what got me the first when i
came out people were saying
like you know why there is no revolution
in north korea
and first of all we don't even know the
vocabulary revolution in north korea
it's a country where they don't teach us
about the word
love there's no romantic love in north
korea i never heard
my mom telling me that she loved me the
only
word that we know love is that written
form of the word where we describe
our feelings towards that fear leader
not about to another human so there is
no word for
love no word for human rights dignity
i mean freedom and that's why you know
people in north korea they don't know
they are they are
oppressed they don't know they are
slaves
you said the information control was so
total that you had
absolutely no idea what was happening in
the outside world
and you believed at that time that other
despite what you saw around you that
other countries were much worse
so even here right nine this 21st
century
north koreans do not even know the
existence of
internet and we do not even have
electricity so
of course in school i never even seen
the map of the world
i never even knew so in school in north
korea they teach me that
they don't teach me that i'm asian they
teach me that animal kim you're some
ways
and north korean calendar begins not
when the jesus christ was born
when kim your son was born so
they cut out entire information and
people literally get executed for
watching foreign information
and that is a crime to be dead in north
korea so you do not have a freedom even
to
travel abroad it's an entire black hole
of information you don't know outside
that cave what's happening
but of course like like the leaders like
kim jong he went to school in
switzerland
the type elites go out but the people at
the bottom
most of them do not even never even seen
the map of the world and we don't even
know what africa other continents other
race
and that was like me
and you described the conditions that
you grew up in so
you're first of all what what stands out
quite remarkably is the degree of hunger
so tell me a bit about what it was like
when you were a kid in the 90s in korea
with regards to eating
so it's a north koreans are
on average three to four inch shorter
than south koreans
because of the malnutrition and i'm like
five
two but most of north korea are shorter
than me so if we are
above 4 10 feet high you must go to
military
so tons of north korean adornment are
around 410
like even below that right now so this
severe malnutrition affects in our brain
development
north korea's average life expectancy is
like if somebody lives up to 60
we think they lived a really long life
like my grandmother
who who died from malnutrition before
her 60
every thought by a dollar oh you should
live long enough to do that
so it is a different plan that we are
talking about
uh being in north korea of course like
only way for me to get my proteins were
eating
you know grasshoppers dragonflies a lot
of
insects tree barks plants flowers
and that's how we survive and most of
people die in the spring
because that's when there's no like
really insects and plants are
and that's where every spring there's
most people dying
and majority people die in that time yes
and you said that for you
and for the people around you spring
wasn't a time of hope and renewal but
the absolute worst time of the year
and so maybe you can explain that yeah
yeah so every spring i remember my skin
should like cut off from the like
vitamin likeness that i would get busy
and it's like
season of death every spring the people
who couldn't wait until the summer so
the plants grow
and that's when like we all know that
tons of people are gonna die
and as you remember i escaped in the
spring
and the march of 2007 one day i had a
really bad stomachache
and my mom took me to the hospital but
in north korea
of course there's no electricity there's
no x-ray machines
none of that literally all nurse using
one meter
to inject every patient in the hospital
and people don't die from cancer in
north korea they die
from infection and hunger mostly and the
doctor
literally told my mom that uh she has
appendix i think we gotta operate
on her like right now in this afternoon
and they do not use
anesthesia it's a very like people not
don't use any station north korea they
would call my
belly open that afternoon and i was
fainting and they said oh she's just
manually she gets an infection she
doesn't have any appendix
but and then they close in a bag and
then
literally from our hospital to the
bathroom they were like
parts of human bodies piled up and
you see children like chasing the rats
eating
just rats even human eyes first
and then children catch these rats and
they eat and they somehow die
from i don't know what it is then let's
eat the children back so this
cycle of us eating rats and they eat a
spike is going to continue and continue
yeah and you said that was happening in
the hospital you also mentioned that
in that episode that you woke up
before the surgery was over because the
anesthetic ran out
it was yeah it was uh it was not even
like actually a
full anesthetic it was more like a dose
of like a sleeping pill like a lot of
tons of it
so you know most of people in north
korea right now even when they cut their
legs open storing their bones
they do not give any anesthesia because
the it's a free health care and vision
do not provide anything for the people
so yeah you mentioned as well and
so we can talk about your familial
situation that
in the 1990s the average wage
in korea was the equivalent of two
dollars a month
and so a dollar ninety a day is what the
un regards as
the the line between poverty like
absolute
privation related poverty and enough to
barely subsist on a dollar ninety a day
and so
north koreans were making as much in a
month
as the u.n allows for poverty in a day
and you describe um
well eating virtually nothing rice was a
luxury
other forms of food especially protein
were virtually unheard of including
fruit
and you in some of the most memorable
sections you described going out into
the fields
with some other children and you were
about seven or eight years old i guess
at this time and catching dragonflies
and roasting them with uh
with a lighter and that was where you
got your protein
that is uh that's yeah i mean i ate
tons of grasshoppers i remember always
even though it was a free education let
me go to school
so in north korea there's no concept of
minor
they or and there's no concept of i they
don't
allow us to use the word i so even
though
like i said i like food they say we like
food
we like our country so and in that
scenario when we go to school they
all view us as a revolutionaries
and therefore even the children when
they go to school even eight seven
nine years old we all have to work in a
manner
construction zones so therefore
children even when they can afford to go
to school it doesn't really
mean much to them go to school and most
of children now in north korea
cannot afford to go to school and stay
at home and that was like my job and
parents go out to
find food children would like clean
and bring the drinking water we don't
even have a sewage
and go into mountains and bring a lot of
the firewood
because we don't have gas or coal
anything we have to find anything we can
find in the nature to cook food
so it's almost like 16th century of
lifestyle that
we go to the river and we bathe in the
summer time and
in the winter we don't bathe and only a
few times we take
baths and that's why syria sometimes
cannot believe that
this is the same life that i'm living in
right now
so you mentioned earlier the class
distinctions that were drawn
in north korea and this is a
characteristic of other
totalitarian states including those
predicated on
hypothetically predicated on absolute
equality you saw this happening in
in the stalinist era and also in maoist
china
where if your family members were
associated with a group
that was deemed oppressive
then that still might impede your
chances of
survival let alone progress three or
four generations later
so you and i believe your family if i
remember correctly
your grandfather or great-grandfather
was a landowner
and so what did that mean so exactly
that's what north korea does right now
they still have this thing called the
guilt by
association so if one person does wrong
in north korea
it doesn't mean just you or the one get
punished
three to eight generations gets punished
so when there was
one high ranking official escaped they
killed more than 30
000 people because of the one person's
defection
and that's the cause that i had to bear
me speaking out afterwards of my three
generation family back in north korea
that
punished so that's like that my great
grandfather i think
were small landowner before the colonies
and everything began in the
1900s only that time because of that
that my grandmother was her
status was down and the
trickiest thing about north korea's
status is that there's not even
something called
marrying up some other countries if you
marry somebody from higher status you
can
go up with them but in north korea
there's only going down
if your high status margin is somewhat
low you go down with them
that's how they prevent mixing different
classes
and right and so that's one of the
consequences of this idea of group
guilt and so the system is predicated on
the idea or was predicated originally on
the idea that
the landowning class was oppressive
tyrannical and and well they were
thieves
they were immoral thieves essentially as
an entire class
and and then that class guilt became so
pervasive that
it wasn't escapable across generations
that's where the idea of
group guilt takes societies
and how would you contrast that to what
you see in the west
it is so it's unbelievable like
i mean i went to school in america to
university and
or talk about this you know i mean
america also had a slavery
and like all those oppression but now
they are collectively being guaranteed
for their history and
how many generations ago was that even
and then people still trying to punish
people who were not doing it at the time
and how do you choose your ancestors i
think that's what was the hardest thing
for me to be north korea is that
i mean i wish i had that option to
choose those things
back then but you it's not within your
control
and now also in america i see these
trends of people going after
people who ancestors more perhaps the
like slave owners
but how is it even relevant to that
individual right now who they are
it's not only they contributed back then
so this idea of like
you know the scared collectively we
associate them and
i just never knew that the rest of the
world was gonna be also like this
in a different degree but this is
something that mainly north korea holds
against its people
they literally call your blood tainted
because your father your great great
grandfather did something
that means you are forever your blood is
tainted you are not like redeemable
and almost now in america i see that
because of my people their
ancestors on the slaves they are like
reading over they should be forever
guilty about their privilege
and like the idea of this word guilt is
also
very it's very hard to even look at this
and it's so heartbreaking why would you
cause that kind of shame on other humans
why it's not their fault at all
yeah well that's a good question but we
why you would want that to happen
well i think it's part of a demand for
some hypothetical radical
equality i mean it it is the case that
some people are born
we're all born with different advantages
and disadvantages and
some of those are linked to our
ethnicity and our race from time to time
and
there's an attempt to at least in
principle level the playing field but
it gets very dangerous when you try to
equalize the outcomes and when you enter
the realm of guilt
by group that's a catastrophe everywhere
that's ever been instituted it's just a
complete catastrophe
because exactly the same thing happened
in the soviet union and in maoist china
your family your father in particular
but also your mother
they and many many koreans in the 1990s
when things fell apart so
catastrophically
there was an the emergency re-emergence
of
free enterprise in some sense it was
illegal
highly illegal but tell us what your
father
and your mother did to survive so as you
say
in the 90s until then so in nursery
right now
you cannot own cars you cannot own
houses
everything is private so no private
property north korea
you don't even own yourself everything
is state-owned
so therefore trading is illegal that is
a
is a ul committing of crime but after
the
90s the slovenia collapsed people had to
find their own miss to survive
outside the north korean government so
the regime created this ideology called
duty ideology self-reliance ideology
so they told people okay you alive on
your own we are not gonna give you
public distribution you should figure
out on your thing
then like how do we figure on things we
don't have freedom we cannot even trade
so people started getting into this
thing called the black market
but all right so simultaneously so what
was happening in north korea
simultaneously was that
the centralized government distribution
system collapsed completely when it was
no longer subsidized
and the north korean government decided
that everyone was now
on their own while simultaneously making
any ownership and any trade whatsoever
illegal and punishable with extreme
punishments so you were on your own
but forbidden to do anything that would
get you out of your
condition of starvation and privation
exactly
i like it now i'm thinking back
people said like oh what were you
allowed to do in north korea
i literally sat down one day like what
was i allowed to do on my own
literally just breathing that is the
only thing that i was allowed to do on
my own
the regime literally tell you what to
read
what to listen to they even send you
prison if you dance in the wrong way
if you wear jeans they say it's a symbol
of capitalism they send you prison
if women wear like skirt like a pants
sometimes they say oh you got a women
have to wear the skirt
and if you watch the wrong movie and
even the haircut
they tell you what kind of hair it was a
funny joke for the westerners say
i cannot believe in north korea you have
to follow the haircut line
the guidelines that's how controlling
the regime is
they intervene every aspect of your life
and literally
when there are sometimes when we have
even electricity
they would give us this radio that we
cannot turn off
we can lower the volume but can never
turn off
at home so they force us to listen to
this propaganda
right and it's stuck on one channel
you can't move it move the station
selector to listen to anything else
that's illegal as well
yes and that's the thing like the regime
doesn't allow us to
anything and then but let us somehow
find a way to survive and of course
that means breaking the rules in north
korean
my father was involved in black market
where
he started selling dry fish sugar
rice clothes clogs and then later the
meadows like copper silver
copper and of course that was illegal
and that's how it was sent to prison
camp
right and so he started to trade
and you mentioned in your book that that
the trading as far as you were concerned
that the trading activity that emerged
as a consequence of the black market
gave north koreans their first small
taste of freedom
so what what do you mean by that why did
that strike you that way
because it's a trading is a very
empowering
act because until then north koreans
have to rely on
everything from the regime like
literally even the water
everything but when we started being
creative
and they say okay i can find the corn
like a cheaper price in this
region and then bring it to the other
region and bring or maybe fabric from
this region to the other region
so we start getting more control over
like how we
even think how to look and but it was
like north korea's marketization was
extremely controlled and still very
limited
but that was almost giving the people
now to think oh there is a
life when i take my own control of my
life it's better than relying on
government
who just promise to take care of
everything but who never does
so now the younger generation has placed
its market hydration
and thirst for more freedom to being in
the market system
so your conclusion was that there was a
direct connection between
the the act of engaging in
in free trade say at the personal level
and the idea of freedom itself because
it forces you to
think for yourself any trade when you
trade it's not like
you're thinking about oh how am i gonna
like become a better revolutionary for
the region
you think for yourself like how is it
gonna benefit me
my family if i do this but for north
koreans
thinking for yourself was something so
unheard of
like when we are born the first thing
they teach us how to bow properly and
respect and
the first thing that my mom taught me as
a younger was
not even whisper because the birds and
mice could hear me
she told me that the most dangerous
thing in my body that i had
was my tongue if you sleep out a wrong
word
that is end of our like entire family
plan
that's how much dangerous your tongue is
yes so you you you carefully discuss
your experiences with free trade and
attribute
to that the dawning idea of autonomy and
and individual
freedom whereas the act of trade is
deemed illegal and immoral by the
totalitarians and
that's associated in some manner with
their insistence that
private property is theft and that
capitalism
by its nature which would include any
free trade of any sort
is also corrupt and malevolent
right so all right so your mother you
talked about the restrictions on your
speech that
even the mice had ears so to speak your
mother was almost thrown into
prison camp because of comments that an
uncle of yours made
i believe he was visiting from china and
he
so can you tell that story so when i was
really young uh we had some relatives
from china
he came and told my mom and kim your son
the first king died
and that he said he didn't die from hard
working for the people
because when the kims died they told us
that you know like literally they're
terrible some people kim's are starving
like all of us they cannot even sleep
they work
tirelessly for us how grateful we are
for having a leader who's that selfless
but towards my mom actually she didn't
die from like those exhaustion from hard
working
rather he died from some heart attack
caused by medical condition and then my
mom was a true believer there she was
telling her friend best friend that can
you believe
how far on my bad people are saying like
these ridiculous rumors about our dear
leader
and she was more like telling out of
anger that she heard
it was like she was questioning it but
even that was
so in north korea right now like you and
me and there's one person
three of us sitting here i'm watching
you
and you're watching the other person and
that person watching me so even though
i'm
being a nice person not gonna report or
new i know that someone watching me
gonna report on me
but if that person is not reporting on
me then there he's gonna be also
reported by the other person so
you're being spied and you're just spied
on someone
that kind of system made us to not trust
in another human
it carried our like trust in another
person like we are
always paranoid so that's a good lesson
for my mom to learn even
she thought all her life that i was her
best friend she was a spy
and she told her officials and my mom
almost like risked
killing all of us but the thing is
because she never slipped the water to
another person and she
studied from the intention of defending
the revolution
they like pardoned her and told her
never ever say
something like that ever to anybody so
even my father never knew
what was happening there right so even
though she thought the rumor was a lie
and when she talked about it she was
outraged that was still enough for a
firm and
a full investigation with a tremendous
amount of danger
associated and it was luck in in large
part
that she escaped from more severe
punishment and the fact maybe that she
had small children
definitely uh like right in north korea
like when you have a newspaper
every front page has becomes but when
you turn
in the back of the newspaper you don't
see the photo of kim's
by mistake if you read the newspaper
your family goes through the generation
of this consensus account
so if you rip it oh yeah so it's
it's like if you get a newspaper you're
gonna be very careful
how the photo is gonna be positioned so
every household in north korea have them
portraits of kings if your house caught
on fire
the first thing is now you're holding
your china one out
you have to hold the portraits to your
death
otherwise it's going to kill the
residents of your family again
so this is like the kings are gods to us
they can't they're almighty
that who came with our thoughts i
literally believe that it was like
so north korea copied the bible in
its exact bible kim your son was a god
loved us so much gave his son to us
jesus christ
like kim jong-un his body dies but
he spirits with us forever and ever
therefore he knows how many hair i have
what i think
what my future will be so if we
sacrifice ourselves right now for the
revolution
we are gonna showing him in the paradise
afterlife
so north korea therefore is number one
christian persecution country
because it's so like so they copied it
so like similarly
they cannot show it to north korean
people there's some other ideology like
that
exists in another country so that's why
they don't want a lot of religion in
that way
so you spent a lot of time when you were
a kid completely on your own because
your dad your father was eventually
put in a prison camp and for a long time
and then your mother spent a lot of time
away from you because she had
well she had to do what she needed to do
to raise money so that you could survive
but also she
was trying to deal with the situation
with your father so you and your
you and your sister um how much age
difference
is there between you two three years and
she's
older yes i was eight years old and
she's 11 years old
and you spent a lot of time on your own
months years three years four years
so what would tell me tell me about a
typical day in a typical week when you
were on your own
so you'd get up in the morning you said
the roosters would crow
there's no electricity the roosters
would crow you were living in a city at
that time
that time i was moving around a lot so
initially i was
left along with my sister when i was
eight years old and 11 my sister
we were living like for three years and
then our relatives
separated us our uncle took my sister
and my aunt took me to the countryside
that's how i lived also on our two years
like that way
and so my typical day is like you know
when the rooster
like cries in the summer time usually 5
30 a.m and the winter time is 7 a.m
they're pretty accurate
so north korea can afford the clocks and
that's how we follow the you know
rooster the timeline we get up and we go
to the mountains and do the daily work
we go and the regime also assigns
the children to raise a rabbit at home
and then we skin them and give the skin
to the regime so they can make the
soldier's coats with it
so everybody gets assignments with the
regime
and also the thing is that they don't
even have fertilizer
so they make sure that everybody bring
their
own bathroom stuff to the
school so tons of them so even when
you're a child you get tons of
assignments from the vision
every single one of them associated
something and get your assignment and
get it done
collecting yes well you said that as a
school child
all of your you and all of your uh um
your your friends your peers well as
well as the adults
were all set out all the time to collect
dog waste and human waste and that that
was actually stolen from toilets because
it was
valuable it had to be handed over to the
state
because that was the only source of
fertilizer
yeah so even that so i remember
my one of the my culture shock was when
i was in the trash cans
for the first time in my life because
there was no trash can in north korea we
literally had
nothing to throw away and coming to the
west
where people were having these trash
problems like
where the heck am i and in north korea
even your own poop
it's so valuable that they fight for
food
it's like the worm poop and if you don't
bring the kora
you're gonna be punished by the russian
so
the kisses rather than they even school
they don't study they send out
us to hunting for poops and everywhere
and gather them bring it to school
afterwards
right well that was one of the most
striking parts of the book i'd never
i've read a fair bit about
poverty-stricken
existence under totalitarian regimes but
that was the first time i'd encountered
that particular
wrinkle let's say so all right so you're
eight years old and your sister is 11
and you get up with the roosters and
you have work to do what are you eating
at that point
how much are you eating and where do you
get your food it's
uh it really depends in north korea it's
not when you eat it so random
like what you get that day it's uh you
know that's a thing
i never seen a cookbook you know how do
you find the half pounds of pork
and flour and like scalling like we just
eat whatever we have at that moment
so if that day we had uh potatoes who
were like frozen outside because we
didn't have a place to put them
then they becomes very dark colors
we cook them and then we put lots of
water in it
and then some dried cabbage in it
because
you know usually water fills you up so a
lot of food are has a lot of soup in it
in north korea to fill you up
and you know we make sure that we have
enough food for the
for the evening we divided each meal so
depending on how much food we have that
day
in the morning i'm always like to the
public distribution for each one of us
and how much you can eat per day certain
meal and some days we just cannot eat
and who was distributing it i was the
my sister was a one more like chopping
mousse because she was bigger
she was doing more manual work and i was
the one more like cooking
and doing the domestic work and where
was the food coming from
apart from what you gathered apart is
sometimes my mom
before she goes away like for several
months she leaves us with a few
kilograms of corn
and like other grains then we have to
divide it
for like six days you know we don't know
when she comes out
well you told me to come back you told a
story at one point about your mother
leaving
i believe she was gone for several
months and she left you some money
and you and your sister spent it on
sunflower seeds and
and something else some cookies some
cookies on the way back
from from from where your mother left
from and
then you had no money for the all the
time that she was gone
exactly so we learned that listen the
first time she left us gave us some
money
and then we never had those kind of
money big money in our hands so on the
way back we bought sunflower seed and
some cookies in the plastic bag
and then we had no nothing left for us
and we were not even
so in north korea we don't even have
phones it's not like you can call up
somebody where are you
like a lot of times they go out and they
never come back they might die you know
you know disease or station like or
accidents a lot of people never hear
back from
so going on a journey in north korea is
like
higher chances of you never seeing them
again
and so even though mom would say i will
come back but we never knew she would
and once that happened the first time we
learned the lesson
mom would like leave us few kilograms of
grains then
we would divide as much as we could
so we will never know until she comes
back and you said
that all you ever thought about and your
sister as well was
food and that you dreamed about bread
and you fantasized about bread and you
talked about how much bread you could
conceivably eat and
that you were possessed all the time
with with hunger
i know i'm like still thinking as a
child like i never
ate till i fell full because so i never
knew what was like
limits of my own stomach was i never
knew how much
should i be fed so i feel like full so
as a young man i literally thought
if i even eat the mountains of food i
thought i would never
never fear full so really compare how
much i can eat more
so my sister said like i'm hundred and
thousand then like a mountain and 10
million
and whatever the number whoever comes
bigger and that's how we were just like
dreaming of it that was the only thing
on your muscle but that's the thing
when people talk about like the
civilization right
it falls when you don't eat people like
become
animals you lose all those dignity all
you're thinking is just food
basic survivor and that's what my people
always telling me the basic survivor
yeah and you were at that time too you
were seeing death everywhere as a
consequence of starvation
it's i i still remember like one day my
son i walked by near the well
as i go people bring the drinking water
there's a young man i don't know like
maybe teenager
he lies down and his intestines comes
out of him
and he was still alive and like i'm
hungry give me something but
as a young mind i don't even feel sorry
that's the thing haunts me the most is
that
i feel nothing on my life there's
and because every single thing i saw was
like that
and now i'm thinking was i your sex
psychopath like how did
i feel nothing about it but that's like
being
so desensitized north koreans are like
i think if you're in if you're in shock
you're in shock all the time i mean you
said
in many of the experiences you had for
example that you felt like you were
outside your body
watching and that's a classic sign of of
dissociative stress and you are in a
situation like that all the time
all the time so i
i don't think that you have to consult
your conscience about that it's
in your book itself there's no shortage
of empathy on display
so and i i don't think it's a comment on
your character it's a comment on the
absolute horror of the situation that
you found yourself
in and obviously you were capable of
great loyalty to your family members and
even to some of the people that treated
you very very badly i mean
the the men that you were involved with
in part once you escaped from north
korea
you had ambivalent relationships with
but i mean in some
you you were able to see their humanity
despite the
terrible situation that you had been
placed in by them
so i don't think there's any issue of
you not having the full range of human
feelings
it's just you were in situations that
were so terrible that
no one fortunately no one in the west
essentially can even imagine
imagine being in a situation like that
none of us to speak of or
very small minority of us have ever been
hungry forever
let alone for any protracted period of
time and certainly
not to the point of me of chronic
malnutrition
that's just that just doesn't happen
here and so okay so
you lost your fa your father was
imprisoned when you were about eight
seven or eight and and what happened to
him
what was the consequence consequences
for him he was doing quite well
in some sense by north korean standards
with his trading so he was
he was he was good at what he was doing
and your mother helped him
but he got imprisoned after especially
after he moved up into more
dangerous commodities you said that he
started to trade metals and that he was
hiding the medals
in cars railway cars that were reserved
for
for i think i've got this right for for
kim jong-il
yes yes and because they wouldn't be
searched
yes so at every train in north korea
we only have one trend line and that
goes from one
side of the country to the end it
sometimes takes a month to go
because the low electricity and the
railways are very bad
so and that's why there's owner always
reserve
one cargo that carries the things to
kim's from
and what's in that car just out of
curiosity
uh i mean we hear these rumors they they
grow
i mean the parts of the country that has
the best
land for you know growing up or growing
something like the
best of the best from the country that
especially reserved for them
and nobody actually knows what's even in
there even when the
those people who search that cargo
cannot go
and the people who regards it they have
to do body search and enhance checkout
for them
so that's how severe is controlled so
really nobody knows what they're
carrying inside and my father was able
to
do something with them and then carry
the matters in that cargo
hiding and and he was bribing he was
bribing guards to allow that to happen
yeah and then he got caught yeah and was
put in a
so what kind talk about the prison
situations the pri because just
normal life in north korea is unbearable
by all accounts but the prisons take
that to a whole new level of hell
so what would have your father
experienced in the north korean prison
camp
so there are three types of prisons in
north korea
one is called gualiso it is
concentration camp
usually you're born there so you're
because you grab
like i said one day my grandfather
communism crime then they take the old
the generation to there and it is like a
permanent
living condition there you live there
forever for the rest of your life
and you're born there you can be born
there because of the
group guilt of your ancestors
which never goes away right now you can
never redeem the by the your group
your whatever your ancestors did forever
you're there
so they don't even consider this inmates
a human enough
they don't even teach them whose leader
is they don't even know what kim jong-un
is in that constitutional account
you said they're not even allowed to
look at the guards yes but that is
every deliberation where my father went
was a prison camp
they but those people know what kim song
is
but the thing is they to also treat them
like animals
they don't let them to ever see the
guards eyes
and of course the the conditions are
i mean it's a holocaust of what the
unsightly in 2014 the u.n did
three years investigation and the only
resemblance that we found
in our history is the holocaust this is
a holocaust happening in north carolina
like again and do you have any idea how
many people are in the concentration
camps the worst of the prisons do you
know what the estimates are
they say around 200 000
and what about the total prison
population do you have any numbers for
that
because so many are dying so when you go
to the prison
a lot of them died within three months
so those like numbers are very hard to
like get
and it's the most secretive country in
the world like even though you
the america cannot figure out north
korea so
those we know that their positions we
can even satellites
seeing those public executions happening
but it's very hard to estimate how many
going in and how many dying
after like three months it's hard to
like
calculate the numbers and so your father
was in prison for how long
uh he was sentenced to more than 10
years uh initially was i thought was 17
years but north korea shared the record
it was like i think
11 year sentence prison camp he got out
something for five four maybe years
later for the sick leave
which means he was driving that's the
thing
right he played a trick on the wards
right right
so they he think holistically once you
get killed you go back to prison again
and he he was a very like a businessman
he
learned like cars and get him out and
that's how he
he got him out during the his sentence
and so you saw your father again after a
couple of years how many years were you
without him
i think four years four years i saw him
again when i was 12
right and you and and you described that
in the book and so what did you see
when you saw your father what what what
had happened to him
um so when i was reading this book by
georgio in 1984 it talks about the man
like
winston who had a lot of wits and after
that all the torture he
became empty right like and a lot of
people
like read that book as a fiction to them
but for me that was like my father
when i saw my father again
of course he had no hair he just got a
prison camp
i mean all he got was just bones like
literally skin on the bones
and other things i didn't even feel
anything that's like what i'm saying i
guarantee it's like
i felt nothing he was just so empty
his eyes were just hollow and empty
and then he was starting singing songs
like i didn't do enough for my country
like he was so guilty that he was not a
revolutionary
or whole and if he wasn't him
and in some ways that was worse than
killing him
they killed his soul permanently that he
never came back
until he died he felt guilty that one
day he committed for the regime
to his death but he told me never
betrayed like the cheerleader
and i don't know what he did to him but
he he came out as a completely different
person
so it was not long after that that you
and your family decided to
leave north korea to escape you were 13.
your dad died he died of cancer
yeah and it wasn't long after he got out
of the prison that that was the case
and then you guys decided to make your
way to china
no i i escaped actually so my sister
at 16 she escaped first with her friend
and i told you i said i got my
stomachache
she left me a note to say go find this
lady she will help you to
stay initially we didn't plan to i
didn't plan to escape with my mom i was
going to escape with my own sister but
because i got sick my sister had to
leave first
i found the note and found a lady with
my mom and
told her that she told me if i go to
china
she said i was going to find my sister
right and then i mean but when you're so
desperate like you don't even know what
china is like we don't have internet to
look searched and what's going on in
china
just hoping because china is the only
place that had the lights at night
and if you look at north korea from a
satellite image
it's quite interesting because the
entire country is black at night and
it's surrounded by the bright lights of
south korea and all of southeast asia
but you have this
immense territory the whole north of
korea that's
completely dark and you talked about
standing with your
boyfriend at that time looking at the
lights in the distance of china
but you didn't know anything about it at
all and had no idea what was going to
happen to you if you
escaped into china no i did not even
know
what was china i just saw the lights and
maybe
if i go where the lights were i thought
maybe i
would find a bottle of rice that's how
innocently we thought about it and
right and some of that motivation was
direct hunger right you were
you were hoping to find somewhere where
you could at least get enough to eat
yeah it was that's the thing it's
something when people say you're so
brave that you risked your life for
freedom like no i wasn't
i didn't even know what freedom was then
like how do i know what freedom is
and i just was literally escaping to
find some food
to survive from hunger
and that's how we crossed that frozen
river that night with
my mother and myself when i was 13 years
old to china
leaving my father behind back in north
korea
so tell us what happened
tell us about what happens to north
koreans as they move
with the traffickers into korea because
that's a whole
story in and of itself and it was
something you had no idea about
i know this is a thing like people the
world is obsessed talking about slavery
but this is a slavery that
happening just right now at this very
moment that we are talking about this
so there are like 300 000 north korean
defectors are
in china and they are all enslaved by
chinese people
i was one of them in 2007
uh we found this lady miraculously she
would
help me to go to china i didn't even
know why she
brought the girls so in north korea is
the most heavily guarded border
with the people with the machine guns
and jim zone literally buries
land mines on the border so people would
not escape so entire countries are
concentrating camp
entire border is served we will luckily
bribe the guards we cross the frozen
river to china
and of course the first thing i see was
my mom being raped in front of me
and and you said that your mother
offered herself
as an alternative to you yeah and you
were 13
at the time and that was your first
introduction to sex of any sort because
there was no sexual
education or contact for young people
there was no sexual education and no
romance no dating anything like that so
that was your first introduction
i don't imagine you even understood what
was happening no
i that's the thing like um
i go there and i was like something 60
pounds
i was very manly maybe 50 something but
i'm
so small and this man was like i want to
have a sex with her and my mom's like
what do you mean like she's only a child
and then you say i want to have sex with
her so just take me instead
and he was raping her in front of me but
i'm like i just never seen a sex video
ever never even knew what
rape was that word was not even in my
head i just
seen something so horrible that i didn't
want to see
and after that they took us to this uh
house where
they would like literally make us stand
up make us turn around take our teeth
and everything and
making price on our body yeah now let me
fill in a bit of background there so
the way you lay that out in this in your
autobiography
is that there's a heavy demand for
north korean women in china especially
rural china
and the fundamental reason for that
apart from desire for labor is that
china instituted a one-child policy back
in the
60s and many many female
female fetuses were more aborted than
male so there's a disproportionate
number of young chinese men
who have no partner and
no probability of acquiring one because
there's an absolute shortage of
of women and so you and your mother were
valuable commodities
because of the shortage of women exactly
yes i've got that right and there was a
price on
you were you both had a high value
yeah and so and that's when you entered
what was essentially the world of
slavery
it's uh as you said right now in china
literally
30 million young men has no hope of
finding women in their life
30 million men in china right now
so because of the regime chinese regime
do not want this men to revolt even
because of dissatisfaction with their
lifestyle
in a way regime chinese region does not
crack cracking down on this human right
trafficking either we are almost the
price they are using to pay for this
mcmahon not reward and then
so when we go uh i was 13 years old i
was a virgin
so my price would be less than 300
in 2007 and my mom's price was
that's 100 that's how literal human
being worth
right now in this 21st century and then
each trafficker buys us price goes up
so the second trafficker comes and buys
us and then pay more price
then they sell us to the chinese farmers
or the men
or to sell us to brothers or
prostitution and like a lot of other
like underground words
and sell us like uh products like
commodity
and that's and then i remember
that's the thing at 13 they were asking
so in china
in order to be here you got to be sword
and i didn't even know what to mention
after kim was like what do you mean
you're selling a human
i'm not a puppy like how do you serve me
and they were like no you gotta be sold
here
and they said like literally to me was
that well if you don't want to be sold
you can
go back to north korea we can't let you
guys go back
but the thing is going back to north
korea is a death
like even though miraculously regime
doesn't punish
me there's no chance for me to find food
i mean that's the hardest thing it's
like there's no place for us to go
outside of north korea like if we leave
that country whatever the condition is
it's better than being in north korea
because at least in china we are being
fed
it doesn't matter we are raped tortured
we are at least being fed
and that's how we stayed in china and
decide and they sorted me
separately from my mom because you know
they
can charge two people's price so they
sold my mom
and sorted me separately and that's how
i got separated from all my family at
13. yeah well you
said at the beginning when you went into
china that you didn't tell
the smugglers the traffickers that
you were traveling with your mother you
said that she was younger than she was
and you said that you were older than
you were
exactly because they weren't going to
take you otherwise yeah so
and you had no idea what was in store
for you at that point
also no i did not know but she told me
oh don't tell them you guys are mother
and daughters
to say or maybe aunt or something and
told
my mom you're much younger you're much
older and
because human trafficking was something
that i didn't hear about in my life
i was so scared because in north korea
there's no bad news
every news is a happy news how amazing
we are winning in the revolution so
i never even knew what rape was in
america if you watch
news like somebody raped you know what
babies by north korea
they steal every information from you
like news is not
actual news so not knowing what babies
not knowing what human trafficking is
and just completely into a new just
another like planet
but you had enough to eat yeah and was
that the first time in your life that
you'd actually had
enough to eat were you able to find
enough so that you could eat until you
were full
did you experience that at that point
that's when i learned
another thing is it mattered it didn't
matter that i had food to you again
because i lost everything that mattered
to me like i lost
everything and so i want to kill myself
like i finally get to the place where
there is a food for me
but then that means me being a slave
and i'm losing every single one of them
in my life
and i i was going to kill myself and at
that point this broker told me
if you help me become my mistress help
me with my
trafficking business that i'm going to
help you with your own family why did
you decide to stay alive
what kept you going because my mother he
told me at that point he said if i
don't kill myself and helping him then
he said he was going to
buy my mom because he's the one who sold
my mom to a farmer
right so at that point you were
separated and your mother was
the enslaved wife so to speak of of a
farmer on a rural
on in a rural community yeah so she
she had to be bought back and that's the
deal he offered you
yes and so you decided to stay alive
because you thought you could help your
mother
yeah it wasn't for you no i
i was yeah it was uh my
then my life mattered to something like
it meant
something i could do something more than
that so
he offered to my bring my father and
that's how i brought my father to china
from north korea and that october when
i was turning 14 and then october 2007
i i saw my father again and so then you
were
you were with this man hon
hongwei was that his name way
and you describe a very complex
relationship with him he was
violent and
a gambler so he would spend vast amounts
of money
raised by this trafficking trade
and disperse all of it
in gambling fits and he was violent to
you but you also
believe that over time he came to love
you and
so what do you make of that in
retrospect it's
an unbelievably complicated situation to
say the least
you know even though actually it's a
thing last
year he came out of prison in china
after 10 years serving sentence
and uh i sent him money from the u.s to
help me
and it was for me to
that's the thing i and then i could
actually this morning i woke up from
this nightmare
of my time with him how violent he was
or my day i was like so was hard up like
all those nightmares i went through
but the thing is like nobody's a pure
evil nobody's pure like anger
i think that's what it is like as much
as he was so
evil i'm still haunted by nightmares he
still i said with my parents
he still gave my father the last moment
that i can cherish
and and i think that's life
really is it's not that like simple
yeah so you were with him for how long
two years and
what what what occurred after that you
went to mongolia
what was the what was the trek from from
him now so he bought your mother back
and so you're together living with him
you and your mother
yes you can't find your sister yet at
that point no i couldn't find my sister
your father is he still alive at that
point when you're with hong wei
so yes during that time after finding my
mom
he brought my father six months later
and then my father died
three months three months later after i
saw him again
and you said you had changed
dramatically after you
left north korea you stopped being a
child
very very rapidly right and you started
to take care of your mother and to make
the decisions and
also when your father saw you once he
came to china that he could hardly
recognize you
i oh it still affects me i think that
at 13 i became i don't know what i
became
it it took so hard for me to fear
something again
like when i had my own son actually in
2018 when i met you right at the lecture
that is the year when i for the first
time first something
and like i was so grateful that i was
feeling things ever again
and so at 13 i learned how not to fear
ever
and i don't know how it was possible
even so my
father came and then he died so i buried
his ashes in the middle mountain
and after that homework is like he blew
all his money from gambling he couldn't
even have you said when your father did
come
though you did revert to being a child
from time to time that you would sit on
his lap and that you would
turn back into a younger child
and then go back into whoever you had
become when you went to china
yeah i think there were many versions of
me back then to survive
whatever the virgin that was feeding me
to survive i think i became that person
it just it was so complex i don't even
know like
who was am i which person was am i like
i became so many persons i still think
i just don't even know how that was
possible so
because you know my father before he
died like
he was keep telling me about his
childhood
and and i i think
he just really missed me being a child
i think something they brought that out
of me
so yeah so my father is very hard thing
for me to deal with
but so he died and then hungary couldn't
afford to have us
he couldn't even able to buy us even
food in china that's really bad he
couldn't even
able to feed us so he was saying okay
i'm not gonna let you go
and how do we go where do we go even
though your mother at that point she was
insisting that you sell her again if i
remember correct
yeah i did sell my mom because i
couldn't feed her
she was the only way for me to vet in
china i was being sold again
so i sold my own mom and then gave the
money to homemade and
he blossomed in a one-night game boy
so three months later i
brought my mom make her to run away from
the farmer that i sold her
and then we luckily found the north
korean lady who
operates in a chat room i don't know you
know this
they bring these girls so it was better
than brother that's the thing
i had the option of going to
prostitution or going to a chat room
and 14 and i thought it's much better
than being touched by
men physically than going a chat room
well you said that
with hong wei that you know that was
your introduction to sex essentially and
that it was catastrophic for you
and so well and then you
after after hung way could no longer
afford to feed everyone that's when you
entered the chat rooms
and and you were in you were working in
the chat rooms for how long
maybe six over half a year maybe less
than a year
i think so like eight maybe eight months
or nine month time
and and the people that organize the
chat rooms took the vast
proportion of the money yes i think you
got one dollar out of seven it was
something like that something like but
even that dollar you had to buy
food and clothes and other things so
but the thing is there was better there
than going in the prostitution
and in that chat room we met another
north korean fellow defector
and then she told me there was way out
of
all this which means going to south
korea and then they say
i told them what you mean south korea i
thought south korea was
colonized by america it's like the
horrible horrible capitalistic
country and she was like no south korea
is free and that is i remember still the
time i learned the word free that day
i was asking her what do you mean i'm
gonna be free in south korea
and she of course did not know freedom
meant
freedom of speech none of that she
literally told me
oh in south korea you can wear jeans and
you can watch some tv
and no one's gonna be arresting you for
that
and that's how we conceive the freedom
as north koreans like freedom meant
wearing jeans so i asked her then how do
i do that and she was saying oh then you
gotta
become christians there were christian
like operations in china
if we become christians they were going
to help us
and it was an irony for me or why
because
i couldn't believe like why do we have
to keep believing something to survive
in north korea to believe in kim's
but now suddenly outside north korea we
had to believe in god to survive
but the thing is we are so desperate
like
literally if somebody took me a romeo
like a rock
they asked me to believe in raw i would
have lived
that is like how strong why humans were
to survive
and the christians the christians that
that you became associated
with in china were those chinese
christians or were they missionaries
from
western countries both they were both
some of them from
south korea and some of them from china
and they would have these houses that
make us to study bible
and if we prove our faith to them
they then help us to go to south korea
and that was a deal that we become
christians and they were going to help
us
so at 15 i became a christian like i
they made us to go fasting i mean
like real like manage all our life but
they said god can do more than that so
they
goes like fasting with a three years old
child in our group
a toddler we go fasting and make us
memorize
vibral verses and they come check us
like if we memorize it or not
how do you view that interaction with
the christians in china in retrospect
was there any of that that was useful or
was it just another belief that you
you had to adopt to survive
so truly honestly dr peterson
until i read your book uh traverse for
life
i was i would say this i was so
so against religion because so
right now now i'm gonna do christians at
15 studying bible
and then they found out about what i did
to survive in china
and the chat rooms yes and they i
remember the pastor
was saying you're so dirty
like it can never be washed and he
literally
like some corinthians some verse telling
me that how some things can never be
washed
and how i was so dirty for doing what i
did to survive
and that was actually a lot harder and
some in some ways to going through all
that journey because when i was
going through it i didn't think that was
a bad thing i thought like
something you have to do to survive
because my father always told me
life was gifts you have to fight for it
no matter what
how hard it is you should never give up
on like life
and and then i'm suddenly now with this
missionary telling me what i did was
wrong i should have
died instead of doing something that
dirty to survive
so it was very tough to deal with like
keep thinking for the rest of my life
was it worth it well but also you you
were
at that point too you said that the
reason that you didn't kill yourself was
because you wanted to help your mother
you had other people that were dependent
on you it wasn't just you
and you were still looking for your
sister too you had no idea what had
happened to her at that point
yeah i didn't know so yeah
and but the thing is now what i'm
thinking of that
no matter what he was he was better than
those people talking about
inclusion all of that because she risked
his life through saving lives
those pastors those missions to send
prison for lifetime sentence in china
no matter what people are saying like
you gotta see their actions
and these people actually cared about
humanity that anybody that i met having
all this flowery loving language they
are using
so that's the thing like it's so hard to
understand humanity
that even though it hurt me so long i'm
like forever grateful for what he did
for us
and namelessly i'm like i made a name
for myself if i'm lying people i don't
know but he never did and
he didn't even tell me his name we asked
him like
tell us your name so we can at least
thank you afterwards again
it's not louise for making a name i'm
doing this because of love
love for jesus that he loved us that's
why i'm loving you guys so much
so in a way that he was the only person
who showed me
with the actions that humans can love
another that like
unconditionally so
it's just very complex
so he it was his group that took you to
you and your mother to mongolia
they told us how to go to mongolia
because in desert
there's no way you can make it out it's
like it's a random luck
it's a pure look that's why i think
maybe they were more religious
they were waiting for god's sign to send
us
because it's not like guide taking us if
you
getting into the gobby desert most of
chances like
mostly you're never going to be found by
any human being on earth
so you decided that you would just go
into the desert and take your chances
yeah and that was you and your mom and
then we have
five other people in our group and one
baby with us
so it was a people group and then they
told us
go follow northwest direction with one
compass
and then if you cross eight wire fences
hopefully that's gonna be mongolia for
you
there's a random chance of taking the
luck
and and so why was mongolia a reasonable
target or were you just out of options
because it didn't cost money if we
wanted to go to other countries like
thailand
we had to pay the brokers but we didn't
have money
so mongolia was the by walking crossing
the walks
when you walk you don't pay anybody
so now really nobody escaped through
mongolia because
it's too dangerous now most of the facts
are escaping through
thailand but we were the last people who
ever
crossed the desert to make it too
successfully
so what happened in mongolia you did run
across
authorities yes we did uh
we after how long how long were you in
the desert
we were actually only there one day but
it was uh 2009
in february minus 40 degrees minus 40.
yes in desert in among it's below
siberia so
usually guys would think like nobody's
crazy enough to cross desert right now
in this temperature because you can die
like even within a few minutes if you
don't move
in desert for even 10 seconds you're
frozen there
you are constantly moving every second
and you said you had very you had almost
no clothing at that point because they
told you to pack light
like my mom how come you didn't freeze i
mean minus 40 is unbelievably cool
yeah it's so that says miracle life is a
miracle it's like some things you cannot
explain in a human way
it's just like uh people say it's a lot
maybe you can say it's a lot i i don't
know it was
i remember like everything was frozen
and we didn't even have gloves or
scarves that's the thing
and now i'm not complaining how cold the
chicago is like no
we we were wearing this bear no snow
jackets none of that
and we i all i remember was
we reminding each other we gotta keep
moving because when you are
frozen it gets very sleepy
and like you're losing a lot of senses
and then maybe you wanna rest and then
we will remind you to know we gotta keep
going like dragging each other moving
every second counts you gotta move
and did all eight of you make it and the
baby as well we made it because
initially we have to
drug the baby if the baby cries the girl
is gonna hear us
so we would give him the sleeping to him
to make him sleep
but sleeping in that frozen like weather
is so dangerous thing
so we have to constantly waking him up
like passing around between people to
keep him awake
and he he made it too
so you you were you were picked up by
the authorities
and you were put in a uh a holding camp
essentially
yeah it didn't seem compared to many of
the other things that you had been
through it it didn't seem as awful
is that reasonable so tell us about that
so the thing was in mongolia it wasn't
something physical hardships
we went through so much it doesn't
matter but the thing is
they were this is the thing
later we learned like so mongolia they
they wanted to send us to north korean
side
i mean to the chinese side and then
sounds back north korea
so we literally brought the lasers and
like poisons
to kill ourselves in front of them and
we thought like they were sending us to
china's side but later we learned that
these soldiers had never intention
but they loved looking at our reactions
how do you react really yeah
that's the thing she's so it's so
unbelievable
i know it's like literally i remember
like
trying to comment later tell my mom like
we did everything we could to make it
and we luckily they stopped us
right before we cut our reserves but the
team
who came after us they went too far so
she didn't swallow the poison
and then they took her to the hospital
and she became like
mentally like lost a lot of her senses
afterwards
so it was a game for a lot of people
like
teaching us you know seeing someone like
and i think that's like very hard
at this point like tonight to make sense
of like being a human
like you know it's just so
hard to know this is like the same life
that i've been having it was like some
dream or something
so you were after that you were
reasonably treated in mongolia but you
were also subject to a lot of
interrogation
and why was that because uh one is they
tried to scream the spies out
because north korea sends a lot of spies
disguising as defectors and send them
so they can assassinate like like me
someone who speaks
out or get information who my relatives
are and then send back to north korea so
they can punish the family members of
the defectors
so a lot of the factors just like a
spice can do
but not only that south korea also had a
very like heavy discrimination
towards north koreans and the country is
still
very they blame the victims when it
comes like the
rape you know there's like because of
you gary not a man so
i remember like during my interrogation
he
asked me like do you have tattoo in your
body and i was
15 years old and i was like no i don't
have tattoos like
they were looking for marks of that
would prove that you were engaged in
prostitution
exactly so i was like no and it's like
i'm gonna take off your clothes here
like
are you sure it's like yeah and
that's when i realized like really like
there was no injury at all like there's
nothing better country like
of course there's all degree of bad and
good
and south korea actually is another hard
place for north koreans to adjust
and like two years ago there was a
mother and son died in the middle of
seoul
south korea from starvation because of
the ignorance from south korean public
towards them
they died from starvation in the middle
capital of seoul i mean south korea
so you went through this lengthy
interrogation process in mongolia
and then it was decided and your mother
was with you and
it was decided at that point that you
were genuine refugees
and you made it from there to south
korea yeah and was that to seoul
no from mongolia several months
integration they take us to another two
months of the intervention at the
south korea intelligence facility
then they take us to three months of
re-education and program is right and
that's when they taught you
how to be integrated to some degree into
south korean culture
so tell talk about that too that's very
interesting
yeah so they give us these three months
of training periods where
they introduce us to new planets and
that's once they've identified you as
genuine refugees exactly so then you
then you got in in that stream
yeah once they're proven proven
sometimes they even go through those
like lie detectors with other defectors
they really make sure that you're not
spy
and saying everything is true once that
is proven they
process three months of training period
where
they tell us what bank is right in the
north korea we never know what bank or
atm machine is
they tell us like how to ride a bus how
to ride a subway
you know like like what did you what did
you think of all that i mean you'd been
in china for some time so
this wasn't the difference between north
korea and other countries wasn't
quite as shocking i presume but how
what was happening to you when you
started to understand the massive
difference between north korea and the
rest of the world and
and also the fact that everything that
you had been taught since you were
born and everything your parents had
been taught all of that was
every single bit of it was a lie what
was that doing to you
that was a thing like as you said i
remember they said oh
korean were started by king your son by
americans
and like in north korea literally they
tell us americans are pastors they are
the most evil thing right
and at that point my reaction was so if
everything that i believe was a lie how
do i know that what you're saying is not
a lie
like how do i ever trust ever ever again
and it was the hardest thing ever
trusting it ever
it took many years and when i read by uh
georgia o'rourke's book the animal farm
that's when i realized oh what they're
telling is actually true
but until that point i didn't trust was
asking
why was why was george orwell's book so
relevant to you why did it have that
effect do you know
it's so i was reading this animal from
not even knowing what that is
and it was i was seeing my grandmother
in those
all the pigs and these young pigs then
when they like
later when those young pigs born they
don't even know what life was beforehand
they didn't even know the alternative
life looks like
right because the first speakers were
afraid to speak out
and all that terror they kept styling so
until i was reading that book i was only
blaming the king dictatorship because of
the dictatorship that we suffered
but when i was reading that book i could
see
all these people were voluntarily
involuntarily supporting
in this dictatorship by terror they were
silenced
but it was therefore too that we end up
in this
everybody did something contribute
something make us north korea into
you know the perfect dystopia that we
are reading the book
contributing what are they contributing
by keeping silence but by keeping silent
yes when they had something to say
exactly because
when it came to me doctor like i didn't
even know
the word oppression so if you know
you're oppressed you're not oppressed
but to me like in north korean young
generation
we don't even know we are oppressed what
is that
but my grandmother knew she experienced
before kim she lived through japanese
colonialism like she lived through
before camps
but because of that their feel of losing
their life
and their loved ones i'm sure they had a
reason
like not to speak up but because of the
fear
and not standing up for the rights just
now north korea is a point where people
don't even know
what life can be look like well
solzhenitsyn was convinced
that a totalitarian state could not
exist
unless everyone was participating in the
lie
and that the most potent
anti-authoritarian
action is to tell the truth and
and that means to say something when you
have something to say because the old
not because you're brave but i think but
because the alternative is worse
yeah that's and it was orwell it's so so
interesting to me that it was orwell
that
that that opened your eyes to that i
mean it makes perfect sense but
but it's still really something
yeah i know it's like that like that
book i think that's when i realized oh
everybody was responsible and
that's when i started thinking about
speaking out
that's when you started thinking about
speaking out i see i see and so you made
a conscious decision at that point
yeah why why because i knew the price of
silence
because like that that was a price real
pain right like not even
knowing like that's the thing like when
people said why no revolutions
because we don't know we are slaves in
north korea how do you fight to be free
when you don't know you're a slave
and that's a different thing like the
fact that my people don't even know
they're oppressed
that's the thing like what carries me to
this point about my father is
not like he i of course i would be
grateful he'll
ever lived in freedom in one day but
the heartbreaking thing is he didn't
even know life
could be just free and life could be
this beautiful
he didn't even know that like life could
be so
different for other human beings i just
wish he knew
before he goes so he doesn't remember
his
life so heart is fearless with the
sadness you know
and that's the thing with north koreans
we are talking a different theory of
oppression
you don't even know life can be this way
and yeah
so that was my time of understanding
what happened
and started believing in this freedom
so you're in the re-education process in
south korea learning to be
a south korean learning to some degree
how to fit in the culture
learning to some degree how to be free
yeah um
did you start reading at that point or
when were you and
when were you for example when did you
encounter orwell
was that when you went to university
later before
my university so when i was 16 i think
16 years ago and how did you come across
the book
it was uh so i was in this defacto
school because
i was 15 years old almost 16 years old
they did a placement exam for me
and as you said like i don't even know
the map of the world
my grade came out like seven years old
like intelligence
right so you got out of you got out of
the re-education
process and then you you lived where did
you live with your mother after you left
the re-education process plus something
uh like a public housing in the
countryside
where a lot of mentally ill people were
living
and then that's when you decided that
you were going to go back to school
yes that's where i wanted to go to
school but then
if i want to go to school there's no way
i can be going studying with seven years
old
but even though some a lot of the
factors do that they
24 they start studying with seven years
old in the same classroom and i
i want to take a ged so i could
catch up quickly and i went to specialty
factory school where they would help us
studying in the in a ged and a bookshelf
there was just book tiny book called
like the animal farm and i picked it up
because it looked
very thin nothing i was like it might be
easy could read
and that's i never knew that was the
point where my life was going to be
changed
that's that's really something so then
you went to school
and you had to convince the
authorities to support your desire to be
educated your plan was to go to
university how in the world did you
formulate that plan
how did you even find out about
university i mean i guess you knew that
already in north korea you knew
sorry you knew that already but why did
you why did you decide that you needed
to go to university what was driving you
uh it was so i remember like that they
were asking me what do i do
after like kids here after the education
what do you want to do and i told him
like i want to go study and it's like
why you know like studying like it's
south korea's most competitive countries
and when it comes to education
how are you gonna compete you know
there's no chance for you to survive
i wasn't even speaking abcd alphabet
english at that time as an adult
so but i don't know that's the thing
something was in me
was thirst for knowledge that i always
knew that i want to study i wanted to
learn how the word worked
so i kept that and
keep keep getting back to books i was
reading like 100 books a year
and just but also the reason i was
reading books is like because
there was such a high discrimination
nobody wanted to be friends with north
koreans anymore
in south korea and everybody told me
that i was a failure
before you might begin it's like you are
never gonna be competing
you are never gonna be in this
competition so only the books were the
ones telling me that i could do it
the books were yeah only the books were
telling you because every book says you
can do it right but
everybody that human being i met was
telling me i couldn't do it
so i just keep reading books yes well
you can make contact with
great minds that encourage you through
books and thank god for that
right that's what they're for
so and and you so you got your high
school equivalency
and how long did that take you i had to
do the
from the elementary to high school so it
took like
over just one year one year you did all
that one year
yeah so i went to college at 17.
at 17. so you passed your g and you'd
only had two years of education in north
korea but most of that time you were
like
working working at manual labor yes yes
now you could you you how was your
reading ability in northern korea were
you already literate
no a little bit but then also their
vocabularies were so different in south
korea
like the like we don't know what
shopping mall is because we don't know
shopping
right like what's the supermarket what
is dry cleaning
so i had to like write down like it
wasn't like
english to south korea was easier
because i already knew the concept
but like learning about gay even i met
somebody gay and telling me
he thought he helped me and he told me
baby don't worry i'm gay
and then like what gay is understanding
a concept takes you way longer than
learning a language
so that took longer for me because it's
exactly the
1984 the georgia where it talks about
double speak
who controls the language conjures
thoughts so north korea purposefully
eliminated the words like stress because
how can you be stressed
in the socialist paradise so they get
rid of stress they get rid of depression
they get rid of trauma
they get rid of all these concepts that
people know here
we don't have in north korea so i think
that was very challenging
than even learning new language
so is it fair to say that you taught
yourself to read
and you got your ged equivalent you did
that in one year and so you were ready
to go to university at the age of how in
the world did you do that
how much time were you spending every
day studying
uh i didn't so that was a funny story i
ended up in the er and then like they
were saying you're managed
because i didn't have time to eat i
forgot to eat
so even when i was sleeping i would turn
on the like a ted talks or npr so i can
like listen my brain still kept working
and even when i was sleeping i would put
the books behind my pillow so the like
knowledge really going to me i was
obsessed i was
crazy you were obsessed with yeah i was
i was
completely obsessed with the learning
and how did you manage to
survive economically during this time
how did your mom and and you make money
i know you got some money from the south
korean government right
was that enough to get you through that
first year or what happened
no they give for the six months they do
they help you to pay yourself for
cell phone beers and the house house
like the
amenities where you pay the utility
bills
but after 60 months you are on your own
so you're completely obsessed with
studying to the point where you're not
even eating
and and we should also just stress here
it is
definitely the case that the education
process is unbelievably competitive in
south korea as you've already pointed
out
far and above what people in in young
people in north america can imagine
or in europe for that matter and so you
were facing
very very heavy competition so
but you got obsessed to the point where
you weren't even eating
that's amazing because i would have
thought that you would be more motivated
to eat after what you do
than virtually but you were hungrier for
knowledge than for food
despite and you had been starved of both
exactly
i was uh i was working at this two i
don't know you know
something could die so it's like a one
dollar store
in south korea the japanese branch so i
was working there as a part-time job and
i was minor
so my mom had to give the like
authorization that should
let me work and then i was working his
wedding horse
like serving food as a waitress so i was
working
and then my mom was also doing the
dishes and helping me
and i was living in these rooms in seoul
because i was studying
where underground i didn't have a window
and i still remember those times i was
so happy because i had a goal
like i was you know like this tiny room
where you can just stretch your feet
like barely i'm like five times tiny
in their room i was like living there
all i had was books
with me and dream yeah well a room full
of books isn't small
exactly it was it was large yeah right
absolutely absolutely
so you got your ged and
then you applied to university
for in a competitive program and they
there was still trouble with you getting
in but you managed it how did you manage
it and how did you decide what you were
going to do
i was going to study criminal justice
it was i saw so much injustice
and even in south korea so so much of it
i really wanted to understand how that
worked
you know how how what this thing is
called justice
so i i'm grateful they gave me all the
opportunity to study that program and
but now uh it's uh i it's just such a
like i don't know how
i was going through all of that but
somehow
back then i had a drive that i never
even knew i had
and so you you were at the university
for how long
four years was it a year degree it was
four years degree but i only did three
years and a half
before my last semester i went to
columbia university in new york and
switched my major there
okay okay now in korea was that
at the same time you were also working
for at a korean
television station okay so there's a bit
of a detour there
you were you were cast in some sense as
the north korean paris hilton
so that's extraordinarily bizarre so so
t tell me about that what happened now
i'm seeing criminal justice in a
tough university very competitive
program doing this physical training
to become an intelligence officer later
and then
i get a call from tv producers saying
they are trying to make a show
because until that point north korea was
portrayed as very just heartbreaking
documentary you know people with like
looks like robots when their dear leader
dies
really looks very inhuman but they
wanted to make a show
entertainment not a document
entertainment show
bring young girls they thought was
pretty
putting in a beautiful designer clothes
clothes and
studio put them in a makeup and then
talk about their life in a lightly
so their show model was a chat with
different ladies
and they had that before beauty is from
the russia poland america now they are
going to do that with north korean young
young girls i didn't want to go on i was
like no of course i'm not
but then they told me you know south
korean shows are super popular in china
and all other east asias
because you lost your sister you might
be able to
your sister might be able to see it and
then find you in south korea
and but because before that i was
looking for my sister on the one
educational program
and they saw me there and then found me
how that's how and they
they knew that talking about my sister
always gonna get me
so that was a thing that was a deal for
me to go on the show
and talk about my sister and hopefully
she sees and come to me
because i was still looking for her but
the thing is
uh because i told them about my father's
black market business before his arrest
they thought um of course how do
how do i know whose parasite is i don't
know but they needed a character for
each character in the
show business that's what they say you
know you cannot be complicated you got
to be one simple thing
everybody gotta have characters and then
they name you
so i was going into out of nowhere to
show business
it is unbelievable it is unbelievable
it's also unbelievable the role that you
were cast in
it's so it has such a con it's it's such
a contrast with what actually
well with what what the reality of your
life in north korea really was
but the thing is in that show
i learned actually what i went through
was nothing
doctor like i was in a way of
some sense of parasiting because
they went through like literally cam
cannibalism is a weird thing in north
korea
and i i i would not wanna
people say oh don't dehumanize this
stuff why are you talking about those
things but like
what i went through wasn't even close to
what other people went through
and what my sister went through in china
who decided to
never ever talk about ever again in her
life
in that seven years what i went through
was nothing
that's that really that three years of
being on the show and
hearing other how other people managed
to survive
maybe me was like oh my gosh i had this
so easy i'm so grateful
i feel so grateful i i searched this i
don't know how i got that lucky
so you're taking criminology and you're
three years in and you're doing this tv
show on the side
and you discover your sister yeah she
did come to south korea and she saw the
show
eventually she did and you reunited with
her in
south korea yes she i i found it when i
was 20 years old
seven do you do you see each other now
now
my sister is a teacher in south korea
and
we see each other often but because we
live in a different country i'm in
america
she's science south korea right but you
have a familial relationship it's just
distant definitely yes yes okay so so
now you're
now you said that you ranked
30th i think out of 94 students in the
program
yeah so you were able to hold your own
against the
intense competition yes i do
my best yes apparently and
then so what how in the world did you
end up at columbia
now you don't write about that do you
write about that did i miss that
no i didn't write it because it was
after okay okay so now we're getting to
the point this is past
so i just remind everybody that we've
gone over some of the details that that
characterize
um this autobiography um in order to
live
so now we're moving a bit past it
because it was published in 2015 so
there's been six years in
six intermediating years so how in the
world did you end up
at columbia what what happened so
so one day i have a friend in america
told me do you want to go this
conference
called like the youth leaders gathering
in ireland
and in south korea in 2014 i never even
been to europe
and i don't even know what island is i
thought it was somewhere like in uk
or something and then they say uh if you
participate they would pay your flight
acknowledging for free
every south korean stands a dream is
going to backpacking in europe
so it's like oh my god i got this at
once a lifetime to go to europe for free
in my college and then so this is a
conference called the one young world
they bring the youth leaders from every
country
so they call the north korean embassy in
the uk saying can you send the
delegation to us
and two we just need two delegates from
each country north korea vision toward
them no because they have to spy on each
other we can only send three
so they said okay how about we sponsor
two and then you guys sponsor one so you
can bring three
and the nurse question no thank you and
that's okay then we're gonna
look for defectors because they didn't
want to sponsor for three people that's
how they found me
through my friends so in that conference
i applied to become a delegate speaker
along with other 34 delegate speakers
i was a really average person and then
uh i did a lot of three times
like the interview with them i selected
as a speaker at the end
and all other many many speakers
together and
there i shared about what was happening
to my people in china
how the chinese role on you know being
silent
and still they are aligning this human
trafficking happening right like
if you see the girls captured by taliban
like
michelle obama have no problem standing
up for girls captured by her boko haram
so many people talk about these girls
but many come to north koreans nobody
talks about it because
they don't want to upset chinese regime
so my speech in that conference
really became wider and that's
and that's what you focused on in that
speech yes i was only focusing on
my like the women's what we are going
through in china
and i didn't even plan to be that
special divider nobody can plan it it
wasn't a pure accident
i was in the middle of university
attending i had to go back to korea too
but then speech became very
fighter and then i got a book offered
from penny random house
and then they my agent was in new york
that's how i went to new york
but while i was writing the book i
always loved learning so i wanted to
study i would still want to continue my
study and they told me there was
university in new york
called colombia so that's how i applied
there and then went there
to study and did you did you finish your
undergraduate there did you do an
advanced degree you finished your
undergraduate then
i did undergrad four years there so i
did almost like eight years of
bachelor okay so you had you'd gone to
university and
came out of north korea then you went to
university in south korea
so you got you got to see that culture
as an outsider and then you came to the
united states and you got to see
columbia university so
what did you conclude about your time in
columbia university
what are your what were your impressions
what do you have to say to people about
what you saw
i knew oh my gosh so that four years
from 2016 to 2020
um it was a complete madness
i i became very pessimistic about
the western world after university
because
like so literally in these humanity
classes
even the economics i was studying
economics for two years and later human
rights
the the professor would send me the like
emails oh this
this class we're gonna cover this this
if it triggers you you don't have to
come to the class or don't even do the
reading
i'm a rape survivor i'm a slave i go
through so many things and they say oh
this can trigger the rape this can
trigger this
and then like they every before the
class they say
let's go through what do you want to be
called your pronouns
and my english is not that good i
sometimes mistakenly call
him or she like and then they start
asking me to say they
and then i don't know how to incorporate
in my english that pronoun properly
and it makes me so nervous to talk in
the classroom and
one day i got into fight with my
professor she was saying
uh you know the fact that you're letting
men holding door for you
is you are giving in to their
overpowering you
and i was like you know isn't it
kindness it's a decency i would
go for people too it's not like i'm
trying to signal that i'm powerful than
you
and she was like you're still
brainwashed from north korea
like and i was scenario of course my gpa
is gonna be affected and it's like okay
i gotta really shut up
i gotta try to do my best to get a good
gpa
so that four years i learned
to censor myself all over again
and it became ridiculous like i
literally exactly i literally risked my
life to say
what i think is right and now i'm like
in a country where four years of time
try how to be creative safe space and be
sensitive enough
so and like where am i the group
and it gave me a lot of chaos like
did i become free like was it where am i
is there any truly free place in this
world right now
well okay so you you were in this
university in korea and korean
universities
are intense and so how would you
contrast the quality of the education
that you received and their very western
influence
the south korean university so they're a
product of the western university system
so how would you contrast your
experience at the south korean
university with colombia which is
in in principle one of the great western
american institutions
educational institutions it's so i do
think
south korea is way more technical they
are
way more into trying to teach you the
skill set
like if you know more giving you actual
knowledge
but okay i think americans are very
obsessed
and that was my impression colombia
we're really trying to help you how to
think
but almost like you would shape how you
they are very into shaping your minds
how you think
about something in south korean
study program was more like
oh this is a fact this is what happened
in history this is what we're going to
do this is a modern you're going to
apply to solve this criminal case
like you know this is how things work
but lately though
when it comes to sociology it's been
very
influenced by the western like the
mainstream
education so a lot of anti-western
sentiments was definitely there and
it's just i in korea as well oh yes
definitely all this like sociology
and those subjects is definitely
influenced and south korea is now
becoming a communist again definitely
it's
it is a start trying to see that like
right now south korean youth demand
socialism and
you know freedom is so fragile like it's
it's never
gonna be there if you don't fight for it
and south korea's democracy is falling
and their speech freedom of speech right
now
in south korea like doctor if you send
us leaflets that we use
sent to north korea to free people's
minds so we use standards leaflets
about like you kids are dictators you
are being lied
and that was a freedom separate
expression
that was covered by south korean
constitution but now that just got
became criminalized in south korea
like last few months ago what exactly
was criminalized
uh advocating freedom in north korea
because south korea in the but their
defense is that because we
if we say we support freedom in north
korea and north korea regime saying we
are going to start a war over you
about that so for the protecting south
korean people's freedom
you cannot advocate freedom for nursing
people in the south korea
and what do you think about
this is another thing there's gonna be a
price for being silent
about something like this happening
right it's uh
if if they can come for this how do we
know they are not gonna go after other
rights
that's how it all this cycle begins so
it is definitely dangerous what they're
taking to keep saying in the name of
protection
in the name of this we are gonna silence
you we're gonna silence this this this
and that's what north korea did right in
the name of equality
pure pure equality you're gonna get rid
of you know freedom of speech
freedom of gathering all of this and now
they're left with nothing
only people are allowed to do is just
breathing
so why did you stay at columbia
uh it was a it was my father's dream
for me to be college educated he
i found it was not worth it it was so
strategy
degree that it was so sorry it was so it
was a waste of time
energy and money really that's a
terrible thing that's terrible
it was honestly i tell like my son that
if you want to study humanity in one of
these universities i'm never gonna pay
for it
like i'm so clear on that to my son but
i'm so embarrassed about that i'm so
embarrassed about that
it's so awful to hear that
those universities they were great you
know they were great
yes definitely and it's not that long
ago that they were great
that they did what they said they were
going to do and if you went got a
humanities education you got educated
you learned to write you learned to
think you learned history
you learned to be cultured that happened
it wasn't that long ago it was when i
went to university it was still like
that
when i taught at harvard it was still
like that there were politically correct
murmurings and rumblings but
by and large the university was still
uncorrupted and it and the humanities
are at the core of the university
if they're corrupted if they go if
they've gone
in the way that you're already
describing there's no way the
universities can survive
they're not technical schools the core
of the university was the humanities i
mean look at what joe look at what
animal farm did for you
that's what reading great books does for
people you know it it
illuminates their soul it's not optional
and i'm so appalled that that was your
experience at columbia
it's so awful that you went through all
that and
managed to get to this great university
and
you know and that and that you had to
shut yourself down
and that your basic conclusion was that
it was a waste of time
now did you have courses where that
wasn't the case
did you have courses that were worth it
i i mean so one class i remember in my
senior it was called the western
civilization the music art
art one of the core that colombia had is
the western art
and she still not for long
but then the i was excited to learn
about but i thought at the end of day
this is through the west america is in
the west right
it'll be funny if you want to study
eastern music at the end of the in the
core
and professors like who has a problem
with calling the western civilization
like art
and then every single one of them all is
in their hands because they were saying
there are so many artists
were greater than better than mozart
we silence them erase them all and
that's why we have to now end up
studying these like bigots you know
we're racist
and i'm like and then they were like
looking at me why are you not putting
your hands up
somebody who doesn't have the problem
with talking about western civilization
so that's like i was like do i even have
to do this to graduate
and that was of course necessary to do
that course to graduate so
every every class had an element
of being a politically correct and
shaping you how you think
and i learned how to censor myself so
well after colombia and then
i was freaked out one day like what am i
doing this is how i escaped you know
it's just and i'm so i'm so ashamed of
that
that's so awful
i can't believe it you know it's no
it's no picnic to watch these
great institutions hang themselves
yeah it's
i i literally felt like it's a suicide
of civilization
like we are killing ourselves here and
and that's why like what
i mean that's what scares me is that
when i was so grateful to going to south
korea was also them
of north korea there was at least a
place that was left to be free
and all these people obsessed fighting
for
you know climate change animal rights
gender equality
transgender whatever all these things
people are fighting for
wonderful but then imagine when nobody
is free in this world
who's gonna fight for us and that's like
what terror for me is like
imagine all of us became enslaved like
north koreans
all of us did in that system there's no
one can stand up for
any of us and i guess because i'm
always i always knew that it was
guaranteed like
when i go to camping with my friends my
friends
somehow always a confidence that they're
gonna find food
even though when they're going to the
remote area not me i
always packing this like energy bars
blah blah always with me because i know
like you can end up not having ever
order food so maybe this is a mentality
that in the west
freedom was always there somehow people
think it's gonna be miraculous they're
gonna be always there
and for me like you know it can be not
there that's you know that's why we were
supposed to be educating young people we
were supposed to be teaching them that
no it's not always there it's it's
fragile and you better take care of it
because
the default condition is authoritarian
starvation
and if that isn't happening it's a
bloody miracle
yeah that is and
that's that's where i am at right now
with north korea while of course i'm
fighting for my people's freedom but
there's so much interest like even
hollywood
they do not want to stand up anything
behind the thing
it's challenging chinese communist party
no mainstream no hollywood stars not
nobody in america want to be
behind the movement that challenges
chinese communist party
well i've seen this over and over in the
universities too you know it was often
the case that
it was my psychology classes where the
students learned about what happened in
stalinist soviet union in maui's china
they hadn't been taught at all
they hadn't been taught that tens of
millions of people died in china they
hadn't been taught
about what happened in north korea they
hadn't been taught about what happened
in russia
it was like that never existed even
though the
cold war was all about that and it was
it's appalling it's
and and i i think you you see exactly
the same thing while you're pointing out
exactly the same thing
how blind can we possibly be
you know it's like the people say like
oh he's allergic to so many people but
do you know actually mao killed the most
human beings on earth
he killed like 50 to 60 million people
the chinese communism killed more people
than anybody ever did in our human
history
yes and the chinese communist party
still controls china
and the only reason people aren't
starving to death there now is because
they adopted
but because they had no choice
essentially because
because people did start to rebel to
some degree
they introduced free market
transformations it's the only reason
that china has
emerged as powerful economically as it
is
so what's next for you you're you've
graduated from colombia when did you
graduate
uh january of 2000
uh last year i gotta ask you again i
gotta ask you again
wasn't there at least one course that
you took
there taught by someone that
taught you what you wanted to learn
one course you should know
like if there was you'd know you'd know
i i knew i liked about the evolution
class
about how the humans uh we became who we
are
uh you know going through homo erectus
and hope on a capitalist or that
humanity journey
but then of course they always had a
political correctness element
always in the textbook everywhere so
there's not i like the economic classes
a lot because it really helped me
understand how the world worked in some
other ways
but then of course it's all about like
the payment
gender inequality payments blah blah all
that like macroeconomics has that thing
so it i mean it
i think it figured it out it was it was
good but i don't think it was
worth of that amount of money especially
and the effort to go you can't take them
on like online
look i had professors i had lots of
professors
who were great like i went to this
little college when i was 18
at 17 i guess because that's when i went
to college and
it was just an adventure for me you know
i i got
the people who taught me i had an
english professor
his name escapes me at the moment
unfortunately dennis wheeler was my
political science professor i learned
i remember that from 30 years ago
i can't remember my english professor's
name unfortunately had a
philosophy professor named long and back
like
six or seven professors
and it was a small college it wasn't an
elite institution
and they loved to teach and i had a
group of friends that loved to learn and
it was great like it was great i learned
a tremendous amount
i learned that i didn't know how to
write and they taught me
robin robin burke that was the english
professor's name
he gave me a d on my first paper it
shocked me to death
because i had got good marks in high
school and i didn't know what i was
doing and he pointed it out and helped
me learn to
to write and these people were very
serious they were
we walked through plato and aristotle
and and hobbes and rousseau and
the full breadth of western philosophy
and
and and it was exciting and and there
was no politically correct nonsense and
that doesn't mean that it didn't cover
the political spectrum a lot of my
professors were
democratic socialists not all of them
but plenty of them were so
they covered the political spectrum so
and and i would say too when
when i was at harvard and at the
university of toronto for that matter
that there were
no shortage of professors who were
providing
genuine education that wasn't
contaminated with propagandistic
nonsense and so
i'm i'm stunned to hear that you can't
bring to mind
a single example from your four years
that where you got
see you should have been exposed to
people that had the same effect on you
as
george orwell's animal farm at least
people who
walked you through literature of that
caliber and who had respect for it
that at minimum you should have got that
yeah but they instead told me not to
read jane
or um january because they had a
colonial mindset that's a brain
brainwash you
you know without you knowing it so the
problems of reading the western classes
they were all like bigots and racists
and believe in slavery
so uh it was even
because it's an amazing it's an
amazingly
it's a it's a lie that's so profound
that it's absolutely staggering
it's staggering to me to hear again
even though i've been watching this for
the last 20 years watching it develop
it's staggering to me that it's that
that this can actually be the case that
that that's what taught what's taught
about this tradition
that actually produced the first
emergence from slavery that's ever
existed
anywhere
i know it's just like we in in north
korea his story was forgotten
like we our story begins when kim your
son was born
and everything before we don't even know
what big bang was we don't even know
who shakespeare is like we don't know
who romeo and juliet is and everything
was forgotten other than
kim's revolutionary history
and when i came out what i loved about
was that the continuation of life that
life before kings
that was amazing there was things
beforehand
way way beforehand it was very humbling
to
those people who thought through things
and you were talking about
plato i read the plato's on love
and how he brings these people talk
about discussing what love is each
meaning for them and it gave me so much
like just
insights you know to understanding
humanity
but now well that was kind of the point
i know
but going to colombia the first thing is
like who loves jane ears i i said
yes but you know the problem is you know
do you know the she believing
all those like ideas back then were
colonializing other people countries
and how that embodied in her literature
work
and that was like whoa i mean
i mean so they expect everyone in the
history to think the same way they do
right now at this point exact same time
and yeah which is to which is to
basically memorize
you know 20 platitudes that anyone
intelligent can can memorize in 15
minutes and then
to dismiss the entire world of knowledge
these books when you were reading orwell
and when you were in that little room in
north korea
or in south korea and you had all those
books what were you reading
so orwell affected you who else you've
you you're you've read now who
who's affected you it's in
a lot of ways i remember the
the the siddhartha the novel is a
fictional novel
yeah that book really gave me a lot of
comfort and to think my how to think of
my own journey
and how how what kind of things i need
to focusing on like i could
be focusing on oh my god what i went
through that because
that was very horrible or what could be
focusing on so i read a lot of classical
books
actually and i think now i'm thinking
but it was actually a good thing i
didn't
pick up this political crime as books
but i rather going to time way before
then like 18th century a lot of
literatures
so i think a lot of people shaped me in
some
many many different ways
and now till this day i was just saying
like
reading your book was of course you
heard that many million times but
uh it was you know people said like you
really
know that you are not alone and
um that's the thing when i was reading
your book it just
reminded me of that the struggle that
shared the struggle that we have on
earth
regardless you're born in north korea in
america
there's still people kill themselves in
america life is unbearable for
anyone it gave me a lot of compassion
because
after coming from north korea to go to
new york like right all my 70
of my friends going to therapy and they
tell me i mean you got to go to therapy
and i was like what is
therapy and of course it coming from
north korea what do i
but do you know what trauma is even and
back then i was like the word the fact
that you
know trauma is like you are so
privileged you don't need therapy
that's how harsh i was and i wasn't able
to
empathize with my friends in new york
like they would go
in line for two hours to get into this
like delicious
like restaurant and food to me was
always
quantity it was not about quality i
think why would i be sitting here with
you for two hours and
getting the line right and
and just understanding all of those like
layers of you know
emotions and that was that's why i'm
very grateful for your book and how you
shaped me
what's next for you what do you what do
you want to have happen now
what what are you aiming at so i'm
i'm on the target list of kim jong-un uh
i'm on the
killing list it's been a while but uh i
mean
we know kim jong-un killed his
half-brother in malaysia he doesn't
absolutely care about killing distance
like even saudis cleared their drama
question their counts in turkey and
chop them off so there's no consequences
the world has way no accountability
for these bad guys killing people now
and
i think that's why this justice
something keep always in my mind
where if i'm lucky enough not to get
cared i
definitely i want to do everything i can
to raise awareness about
chinese role on enabling this
dictatorship
people often think kim jong-un is the
one who to blame to running this the
biggest concentration camp on earth
but it is not there is enabler behind
that is
china if without china nursing region
cannot even
a library within one day and right
and so we can say with no hesitation
whatsoever that there is
absolutely no excuse whatsoever for the
chinese communist party's support of the
north korean regime
yes it's a crimes against humanity it is
a crimes against humanity and
we have every every international
community with their stances they have
to come together to tell china that
but now every everybody's bought by
china if
they own africa they own so many
countries
if america loses their ground to china
and then keep saying
and do not stand up for what we believe
in in this country
we we might lose a chance to be ever
free and win with china
this is a very serious battle that we
are in
it's not a joke that like and i think
that's the thing
america is the last chance the western
these democracy countries has a lot of
chance to battery china but
because until in the past we thought the
democracy was gonna prevail
but the thing look at china free market
didn't have the free poli
politics they are developing these ai
machines to facial recognition to
control people in a degree where we
never even imagined before
it is truly 1984 by georgia where they
can even look at cameras to see who's
there
north korea started in their
malnutrition state
they are buying these ai machine spring
on the town
so it sees who the stranger is in this
town or not
putting this like a facial recognition
campus on the border and make sure
everybody was in the place right there
so inner we become forever enslaved to
this
totalitarianism or we break off the
cycle
and i don't know like i can never be
that person
recklessly say we're gonna win in this
battle
and to me this is a very dangerous state
we are all in
collectively everywhere in this world
that we are not safe from this
devil in a communism
that's a good place to stop yes
sorry that was very uh intense
interview um it's been thank you
yeah thank you for you're quite the
creature
i really wish you would have had better
professors
you deserve them now thank you for
everything you do seriously doctors
it it's been you have no idea how it
touches so many
us and me especially and reminding me of
like how good
still humans are and really helping me
not to lose my hope so
thank you for everything you do at
youtube kiddo
your book's deadly and so are you keep
it up
keep it up
[Music]
you